on top of Tom segura's Netflix special
coming out July 4th Shane Gillis has a
brand new comedy special coming out soon
that is being filmed this weekend but
that's not all his podcast partner Matt
mccusker also has a special in the
chamber ready to be released on YouTube
it doesn't end there though word on the
street is two more of Shane's close
friends Mark Norman and Joe Rogan have
already recorded their next specials as
well Joe Rogan has publicly stated he's
not sure where his next special will be
released as the comedian is still
debating between the traditional Netflix
route or the New Age self-produced
YouTube strategy it looks like we'll
have a lot of high quality stand-up
content from a hilarious group of
comedians ready to be enjoyed soon